wir haben uns auch einmal bei ihnen bei
unseren zuschauern und zuschauern
umgehört was sie dazu meinen also
definitiven bat um eine sirene
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt abgeschätzt den krieg
würdet ihr euch da wünschen dass man in
prekären situationen mit so einem
geräusch frühzeitig natürlich gewarnt
er soll früher warst also abgab und ihn
ja nicht nur in berlin sondern auch
manchmal in städten die näher am wasser
oder noch mehr vom wasser vielleicht
betroffen sind als jetzt berlin
aber ja ich denke das ist wichtig in den
städten wo das passiert ist und das
gerade anfängt dass man dann schon so
mitbekommt oder weggehen kann die
sicherheit gehen könnte
solltest du dir explizit wünschen dass
das sirenengeheul mal wieder da so ein
bisschen in das gedächtnis der menschen
auf jeden fall früher einschulen war es
ja auch so zu meiner zeit dann hat man
in der schule auch beigebracht bekommen
für tsunamis gibt's ja auch solche sie
reden damit die vom strand weg gehen und
das ist ja auch sehr sehr wichtig und
sehr gut aber ich finde auch in
deutschland das klassische sehr viel für
bomben und so aber vielleicht für andere
sachen die halt auch mal nicht so direkt
mitbekommen dass auch schon gute idee
wäre weil damit die jungen leute auch
mal wissen halt wie sie reagieren müsste
wenn bestimmte geräusche kommen also in
die sirenen signale kommen ja die jungen
leute die sollen richtig reagieren und
die g-serie geräusche überhaupt mal
kennen es gibt nämlich tatsächlich
mindestens zwei unterschiedliche
geräusche
wir spielen ihnen das erste geräusch vor
achtung achtung naturkatastrophe
[Musik]
zu erkennen an diesen sich immer nach
unten und wieder oben gehen der pegel zu
drehen genau
genau
und dieses geräusch also steht für eine
unmittelbare und große gefahr vielleicht
hochwasser vielleicht ein sturm
vielleicht auch ein bombenfund das könne
neben kann dieses geräusch bedeuten und
eben in dem moment die der hinweis
fenster und türen schließen
rundfunkgeräte an das haben wir gerade
gehört optimal vielleicht radio internet
das sich erfahren kann was ist da los in
meiner umgebung und mich dann eben
weiter informieren kann jetzt kommt die
entwarnung das geräusch wenn die
unmittelbare gefahr vorbei ist
[Musik]
wer langer sehr gleich an halten betont
moment aber dann eben doch er hört man
ganz klar den unterschied würde sagen
und jetzt wird's kompliziert denn jetzt
kommt noch béla anda hat angesprochen
aus dem ländlichen kennt man ist wenn
die feuerwehr ausrückt achtung achtung
feuerwehrleute kommt in die wache alarm
alarm
das hören wir uns einmal an
[Musik]
also auch der sehr ähnlich muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen diese geräusche
sind wenn man laie ist wenn man sich
nicht auskennt fast unmöglich zu
unterscheiden von einander
ich habe es ja auch vorhin schon gesagt
ich glaube wenn ich mich jetzt nicht
damit beschäftigt hätte ich hätte nichts
auf anhieb gewusst welcher ton für was
steht beziehungsweise natürlich wenn man
ein signal hört ist man direkt alarmiert
und schauten irgendwas ist hier nicht
richtig
sie die schöne erkannt nein absolut
nicht obwohl ich jede woche jeden
samstag um 12 ist das glaube ich geht
die sirene an das ist nur ein ein alarm
der hund und holt dann immer mit das ist
ganz lustig weil er macht jetzt die ring
broich danach wird er denkt das ist dass
der leitwolf der da vom wolf ab der hund
also der dieser auch ganz besonders und
der denkt die messe leitwolf der heute
also insofern weiß ich dass es ein
durchgezogener ton ich weiß dass es eine
übung ist aber auch wenn es in der nacht
dann genauso angeht dann weiß ich nicht
was dann
der fall ist aber gut dass ich sie jetzt
hier erfahren sie es